si nous sommes aujourd'hui au knokke
heist ans c'est à dire que le knokke
heist ans est un pays où les médecins
ont pris le pouvoir
c'était une référence à la pièce lautner
jules romains voilà et qu'est ce que
c'est que la sir en vendent pas lésés
quelque chose
monsieur a tout à fait raison il a tout
nié dans son rôle à la ville est envahie
par les patients knoc qui les inventent
un mode et la raison n'est pas des actes
des médecins or la raison tient de films
et de ça et des raisons techniques
qu'est ce que c'est que la science quand
il ya un problème on apporte une réponse
à un problème une réponse et salonique
c'est ça la science monsieur une vision
technique il est dans son rôle et on
peut pas lui reprocher mais il n'y a
rien de pire qu'une vision technicienne
pour définir une société toutes les
sociétés totalitaires sont vu par le
prisme de la technique non j'ai
l'impression depuis un an d'être en
corée du nord où le mot de coville était
le mot de kim il sung et est remplacé
par notre collègue donc au vide dans nos
conversations gérer un peu fort dans nos
plans courir et je peux le permet non
mais ne savait pas qu'elle vous aime
beaucoup et j'aime les parités leur bol
mais là vous ne savez pas quel point j
vais pas forme c'est à dire que je pense
être le seul ici avoir été en corée du
nord plusieurs fois oui je me retrouve
dans une situation où les dialogues les
conversations les récréations sont
toutes contaminés par une seule
obsession locaux vides
or cette obsession ne se justifient en
rien en rien nous avons une maladie un
peu dangereuse mais quand on confond la
dangerosité avec le manque de soins et
non adaptées at soir n'a pas de soi et
la maman dans la mare il n'y a pas de
soin voilà les gens qui meurent quand
vous dites 25 mentions ses vingt-cinq
personnes n'y a pas de soin diakhaté
soignants mais aussi tous les jours est
ce que les personnels comme suit les
jours soins est-ce que c'est forcément
les conneries c'est ce qu'à défaut de
tenues vous pouvez voir un peu de
retenue en outre vous ridiculiser sur
vous vous ridiculisez sous le par les
nazis mais qu'ils aient honte vous réduc
les pieds tout à l'heure vous maîtrisez
les personnes à très hauts
mais chevrolet sonore assez de ce genre
et c'est devenu un brillant
ado non c'est du mépris la corée du nord
les laisser sur votre faim de
spectateurs verront qu'entre être
médecin être intelligent il ya deux
mondes différents pas les gens ce n'est
pas nécessaire si nice est là il y as
après la société du jeunisme une société
du vieux juillet mais quand j'étais
petit il y avait un about un canard ça
s'appelle le génie ci s'appelait nestor
et il y avait un vent de jeunesse david
michel on lui faisait dire à peu près ce
qu'on voulait et aujourd'hui c'est pas
beau c'est pas les vieux ou les vieilles
personnes âgées qui nous empêche de
pouvoir faire en sorte que les jeunes
aient un avenir non c'est au nom des
vieux on a laissé tomber depuis 30 ans a
fait qu'aujourd'hui on édicte des lois
et on est en train de souiller d'abîmer
d'éventrer de paralyser ce qu'un pays a
de plus riches c'est à dire la jeunesse
l'avenir les projets les jeunes
aujourd'hui sont en train de mourir de
saab et ir dans leur fusion au pas les
jeunes un pays un pays qui stade qui
j'ai qui glace tout qui pétrifie tout
pour sauver une part de la population
qui devrait te prête à s'en aller je
suis désolé non je n'y sois au fil de
génisses mme wyss et leurs animations
vous voyez on a envoyé génération
envoyée il ya des générations entières
ou gaston pour les nerfs vous pouvez
même 20 ans aujourd'hui elle dressé
mourir c'est un débat éthique
intéressant et philosophique je
considère pour ma part une vie de 80 90
de la jeunesse c'est nassimah rappelle
le même statut que nuit de 22 ans car à
89 ans on a ça si c'est la même chose
derrière soi il ya toutes les villes
françaises
c'est un second d'une cheminée quand
même mais oui mais vite et c'est bon je
pense je pense il est pénible où je
pense que lorsqu'une jeune à l'époque et
c'est pour ça c'est pour ça sur twitter
du jeûneur il ya six mois terminées et
l'illustration
on me dit non non plus à vous monsieur
c'est pas une insulte monsieur bien
franchement finition qu'en ce moment les
gens sont en train de péter les plombs
et de faire des jeux paix n'a pas les
bons jeux existants